Let's go next to there is just so many people
who want to get on here.
It's very, very interesting.
Why don't we go to let's go to Adam from Dubai.
Adam from Dubai.
What's going on?
It was good.
David, how are you doing?
Very good.
I've been a fan of the show for a while.
What's what's it like in Dubai right now?
Pretty hot.
It's getting a lot bit.
But dealing with this whole Kobe thing.
Yeah.
All right.
Well, what I do for you today.
Yeah.
Like I know a lot of Americans know by how
much the election impacts the world, but we
tend to keep up with it a lot.
And I'm wondering, like, given this to me,
it seems like it's a clear choice between
Biden and Trump, but there's still a lot of
both sides ism that I still see.
Yeah, especially like in progressive circles.
I'm wondering what the rationale behind that
is.
There's a there's a bunch of different things
going on there if there's not one answer.
So you certainly have people who.
So in terms of undecideds, the typical undecided
is center.
Right.
Relatively young and not paying attention
very closely.
So most of the undecideds are people that
could go either way.
Are not people that are on the left.
That's important to understand among those
who are on the left and are unsure.
You have a contingent that just doesn't like
Joe Biden, that that would be just a very
specific thing.
Like, okay, Trump aside, I don't like Biden,
so I'm not going to vote for Biden.
You have the both sides ists who say if it's
not a, quote, true progressive, I don't care
whether it's Trump or Biden.
We saw in 2016 how that failed us.
Trump now has had two and potentially, potentially
we'll get a third Supreme Court pick.
So you have that contingent.
You have people who would be open to vote,
open to voting for Joe Biden, but want to
feel as though as though Joe Biden came and
got their vote and earned their vote.
And for me, you know, I don't need that.
I just look at Biden's policy and I see, oh,
Biden's policy is better.
I'll vote for Biden.
And it's sort of that simple.
So you've got a lot of different things on
the left going on at once.
But most people are going to vote for Biden.
That's the reality.
Some of these anti Biden left wing enclaves.
They're very loud online, but most people
realize what's going on.
Sure.
I mean, I'm not concerned about individuals,
Reddit posts or whatever, but like seeing
online commentators, I won't name on on the
left, I should still stick to their guns on
this.
And when you say stick to their guns, what
are their guns?
Just that Biden's bad and you shouldn't vote
for him.
Yeah.
Like, so saying that no one won the debate
and saying that a like, you know, the American
people still like will lose no matter who
wins, like trying to muddy the waters.
And a clear choice.
Yeah.
And sounds irresponsible to me because if
there's a better choice, you go with the better
choice.
You know, it's sort of like if you really
believe that we're talking about two bad choices.
Isn't there a moral responsibility to act
in the way that that pushes the less bad choice?
Think if you say to me, would you rather have
a sinus infection or covered and maybe the
cove, it gets really serious.
I'm not looking for either, but given the
choice, I would say give me the sinus infection,
you know.
Sure.
Yeah, and and also, like, I don't understand
the like, I don't I don't feel like we have
the luxury to play those games of, oh, I won
but indicated to me, yeah, I want him to do
such and such.
Right.
Given how terrible this situation earliness.
I completely agree with you.
All right.
All right, thanks, David.
All right, Adam from Dubai.
Great to hear from you there.
There he is, Adam
from Dubai.